I always wear this Kyle is in Kentucky
hi Kyle how are you hey good evening
Dave listen for about 20 years and this
is the first time I've ever had to call
okay oh thanks for calling how can I
help our grandmother is nine years old
she she lives on her own most of the
time she does have some assistance from
family we've got a cousin that we have
caught on video he has stole medications
household items food laundry items he
has also got into forging checks in her
name which has now totaled into the
thousands of dollars have you put on
jail no more his arrest he's a thief we
have just installed the camera and and
we can we caught what we thought was
always going on my father is the oldest
of eight siblings so he would be he's
trying to seek guardianship however
three of the siblings do not want my
grandmother to lose control checking and
her meds and so forth so we really don't
know what to do from here or how to talk
talk to the siblings about it
to get something done you know we're
what do we just call the police and have
him arrested okay that'll fix it all
right well you know listen it's scum
that steals all right it's super scum
that steals from their own freakin
grandmother I mean what kind of gum look
how scum ball is this guy well it's gone
on for years and without you no real
proof until recently we now have the
proof yeah yeah
so what you know you call him up and say
if you ever set foot on the property
again we have cameras installed we're
gonna have you put under the jail well I
actually tried to I tried to confront
them he got away from the house about
less than a minute
before I got there it was that close no
you don't have any way to contact him uh
he actually does not have a phone that I
know of currently it does not have a
place of residence he does okay well I
mean you can ride over there and just
tell him next time you're on the
property we're gonna have you arrested
okay
or just go ahead and have him arrested
either one I don't have to have the
siblings permission to do that the guy's
a thief he's stealing from your
grandmother he is if he was a neighbor
next door if he was a stranger if he was
your cousin none of that really matters
he's just a thief yeah yeah that's gonna
be our only option from here you know
your family's screwed up man it's a it's
a well we've got a couple of enablers
yeah we need to hopefully address those
as well they now know what's going on so
I'm hoping this all comes back around
and we can do something about this it's
up to you but I mean you call me to say
you know I don't you don't have to have
guardianship and have to have
everybody's agreement to put the guy in
jail and so he's gonna stop or I'm gonna
put him in jail if I'm in your family I
mean I mean what kind of scum steals
from his grandmother that's just that's
hillbilly stuff man put a stop to that
stuff I know how that works I know a
bunch of them people I grew up that way
there's only one way to deal with that
kind of are dead and that's deal with
him oh man what drama yeah
just slap it down